I want to went to my boss and I said
look I'd like to design these ties
because I think they could be new he
said the world isn't ready for Ralph
Lauren I learned to trust my own sense
everything I've always done it's been
for my own emotion movies and books open
the world for you there was no miracle
there was no snap of the fingers people
we can just say you're wonderful in fact
the way I work is I feel like I move
doing moves and all of a sudden I got a
phone call from a banker and said it's
Lauren your bills are not being paid on
time I want to be baseball-playing won't
be basketball play huh I wanted to be an
actor I won't be dancer cancer is not
only for the poor that's not for the
rich it happens to everybody
he's an American fashion designer for
length apiece and business executive
he's best known for founding a global
multi-billion dollar clothing empire
that bears his name Forbes estimates his
net worth to be 8 billion dollars he's
Ralph Lauren and here are his top 10
rules for success so this all started
with a tie a lot of people think it
started with the polo shirt but it
started with the tie it started way back
right I felt I had something to say
there were no fashion designers when I
was growing up for the idea of fashion
and what fashion has become today was
was very different I was working I was
working at a job and it wasn't sure how
I was gonna be and I what was the job I
used to hang up the returns in a
department store I when I was 16 years
old while I was still gonna high school
and along the way I sort of felt that I
had something to say that was different
and and no one believed me of course I
when I went to my boss and I said look
I'd like to design these ties because I
think they could be new he said the
world has been ready for Ralph Lauren
Wow and I've never forgot that because
even when he said that the world isn't
ready for you I thought that was a
compliment
yes so what happens Bell came along and
said Ralph would you like to come with
me and I said I would I'd like to start
my own division called it polo and they
gave me a draw in the Empire State not
an office but a draw I just I worked on
the bottom of the draw and everyone in
the office thought who was this little
kid working out of the drawer and I took
the samples made these white eyes and
delivered them myself and a bomber
jacket and jeans and that's how it went
when I went to Bloomingdale's the buyer
said we like your ties Ralph but would
you make them narrower and would you we
don't want to use your label we want to
use our own label but we'll give you a
really good order now here I was no
business and hungry and I said to the
buy I said my heart's in my throat or
whatever the expression is I I would
love to sell Bloomingdale's they were
the hottest store and young hot store I
said but I can't tell you I'm closing my
bag and I'm not going to sell you six
months later they called me back Wow
and they said Ralph we can't find your
toys anywhere and we want to buy him and
we want to put a rack in rack up ties
amongst other ties and that was it the
breakthrough was they bought it the
breakthrough for me is that I've learned
to trust my instincts I learned to trust
my own sense because the normal thing to
do is say I'll make it any way you want
to I mean that's how that's how the
world was you want to I want to sell you
the ties you know maybe I'll have a new
fashion for you next year let me buy it
my philosophy was that I love these
times I made them they were not just a
business to me they were they were my
voice to myself everything I've always
done it's been for
my own emotion and we've never done for
a brand or a label it's it's it's
because I feel it and we give it a title
event it's what takes it away from me
when I grew up you know in terms of at
that age what I don't know if I had an
identity but I I remember years ago I
don't know why there was a pair of suede
shoes in a store blue suede shoes and
before Elvis Presley I have a song
called blue suede shoes but I I would
pass on my way to school I would pass
the store that had these sweet suede
shoes and and I said I gotta have some
shoes how am I going to get and every
day after school like passing shoes and
it was ironic cause I was I was not only
thinking of clothes I was really you
know going out with girls I was trying
to look good see what was sharp and so
you finally get that pair of shoes I
don't think so but I have I have I made
them what happens later I I think they
were inspirations you know I think when
you're younger you have visions of of
what your life could be and and I said
earlier that movies and books open the
world for you and so maybe those shoes
represented something to me I don't know
at the time they just look great years
later I think I love shoes and I've been
able to I think in some levels growing
up was the platform of things that I
wanted as I got older and and so instead
of looking at a store I'd say I I want
to make those shoes but I could make him
better so on some levels I had a very
good childhood and I had the clothes and
some levels hand-me-downs but as I grew
up I was inspired to to see if I could
do things that were better
grew up in America I have the same
dreams that everyone else had started
where I started my dream was to have a
nice house with my family hmm
to have a nice car to have my kid good
schools to do all the things that
everyone wants mm-hmm and as I got there
I was able to do that and and as I
worked harder I was able to improve it
there was no miracle there was no snap
of the fingers right and it was
confidence and I think confidence builds
as you go on if you have a good success
closing the door on Bloomingdale's was
at one point sort of crazy and at the
same time was amazingly powerful the
fashion is changing so fast and a
competition is coming up every day with
all these young designers what has kept
you going forward like this you just
somehow you know I've always admired
longevity I've admired people that were
not of the only moment people that can
cap can carry it on the they're actors
there are musicians there are people
that came up in rock and roll and the
great ones stayed Frank Sinatra lasted
you know
the whole pile of names that you know
Paul McCartney and the Beatles they
didn't last for five years at ten years
they lasted for 40 years
I admired longevity and I admired
consistency and I admire the
individuality of holding your own
standing and fighting for what you
believe in and I think if there's
anything that I really believe in is
that and what made me keep keep going I
didn't get great reviews every year I
didn't people didn't just say you
wonderful in fact they couldn't care
less Ralph Lauren but the consumer loved
Ralph Lauren it's not the fashion editor
where are you most yourself and when are
you most yourself
I'm always myself it's great answer but
like sitting here on the porch right now
in in your dude stuff see part of me
it's a part of you I'm not a cowboy all
the time I don't propose to be a cowboy
you know but I love the West
I love ranching I love the idea of it is
it like creating absolutely little
movies the way I work is I feel like I
move doing movies everything I do
if you said just design that dress for
that girl or design I couldn't do it but
if you say she lives in a mansion or she
lives in Soho and she's an artist I
could design exactly how she should look
how her hair should be what she should
be wearing and I create a world and I
pin her up on the wall and I said now I
know what you need what was some of the
most challenging moments in your career
well I had when I started out and made
the ties and shirts I started to become
successful it was about after about 10
years I heard I had started my company
by borrowing $50,000 from another person
in the industry he left me the 50,000 K
my partner and so all of a sudden we
were growing and and all of a sudden I
got a phone call from a banker and said
Miss Lauren your bills are not being
paid on time and I had a team thinking
they were doing all the right things and
all of a sudden I found that I was in
trouble financially because I was taking
on too many things and no one told me to
stop and I was being applauded for many
ways but a lot on some levels on the
financial level I was not being
applauded and one of the bankers came to
me and said Ralph you're almost out of
business what are you going to do that
was ten years after you started that was
about ten years after I started but I
remember the pain
and and I took everything I had saved
which was $100,000 and I put it back in
the company so hundred thousand dollars
was all I had left and and some and I
decided to license some of the brands
and have some money coming in and so it
gave me a shot to go out and hire better
people and and so that was a very
important moment seeing success in terms
of artistic success but failure in terms
of a company that could go wrong in its
not in its finances and that was a very
important time and so that was a very
major moment in my life I've had those
every five years I had a show where I
remember doing a fashion show and the
clothes weren't ready and the tailors
were ironing or selling the clothes as a
girl is about to walk out the runway
what did you figure out what happened to
to make it so late too many of not
getting the right professionals not not
planning well not thinking you got it
going and all of a sudden didn't I said
to myself as I was walking on Broadway
not knowing where I was going I said
this is never gonna happen again
did you always want to be a cowboy I
want to be everything he wanted to be
everything all at once I want to be
baseball player I wanna be basketball
player huh I want to be an actor I wanna
be a dancer you know and I think my
whole life has been
has been actually I wanted to be Batman
if you don't that's a secret I'm telling
you and everyone else but the ability to
stay young the ability to enjoy to enjoy
what you join when you were kid not to
give up the hope and the excitement is
very important I remember meeting a
friend of mine name was nina Hyde and
she then told me that she had breast
cancer
I went to the fashion industry and said
let's go after this and give it some
exposure and support and I got very
caught up in it and then she passed away
and then one day I said you know what
else can I do
I worked on breast cancer I certainly
didn't solve it but maybe there's more I
can do and I went to sloan-kettering I
was called to Memorial sloan-kettering
and it was in that meeting that had the
opportunity to tell mr. Ralph Lauren
what I saw is the problem and what I
thought could be a part of a solution
they stood up and shook my hand and he
said dr. Freeman I will help you and
that is how the Ralph Lauren Center
again
he talked about people in underserved
areas are dying because they can't get
help
I felt that sensitivity helping someone
who doesn't have the funds it doesn't
have the know-how cancer is not only for
the poor and it's not for the rich it
happens to everybody we really try to
educate people about what are the things
that they're doing that are putting them
at risk for cancer I'm really grateful
the chemotherapy process itself was kind
of grueling but they really helped me a
lot here everyone that you do with have
justice warm personality that is very
inviting and very comforting considering
that the situation that you're in
a thousand people are here today and in
England and in Milan we have a walk and
a March for a very good cause and I want
to thank you
you
we are here tonight because Ralph Lauren
is a lifesaver long before everybody was
wearing the pink ribbons Ralph Lauren
was galvanizing the fashion industry's
response to breast cancer
the generous investments in the Royal
Marsden by Ralph Lauren a dedicated
supporter of cancer research
incredibly generously they will fund the
Ralph Lauren Center for breast cancer
research
a world-class research facility at the
Royal Marsden Chelsea Hospital
cancer is a scary it's a scary on every
level and whatever I can do in this
world to help a little bit I try to do
it used to be cancer with a whisper or
breast cancer was a whisper you women
didn't even talk about they know about
it
today it's not that way and I think
that's progress and we're talking about
research into the future this is a an
ongoing commitment they stay with the
Ralph Lauren breast cancer Research
Center at the Royal Marsden will bring
together world-renowned clinicians and
scientists to really take forward our
research into better diagnosis and
treatment of breast cancer I'm enormous
ly grateful to Ralph Lauren for his
generosity you should know that what you
do saves lives and gives hope to
thousands of people
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because Abigail Rosser I hope
I pronounced that properly asked me to
so there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave it in
the comments below and I'll see what I
can do
I'd also love to know which of Ralph
Lauren's top ten rules had the biggest
impact on you leave it in the comments
and I'll join the discussion thank you
so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon